what a Thanksgiving I had last night let
me tell you let me tell you folks if you
don't have a family you should be
legally prohibited from celebrating
Thanksgiving because it's really not for
you and I said to a friend of Mike's
you're both gonna be in LA now I could
have flown home to be with my family but
I chose not to because I'm gonna be back
in town for Christmas and I'm like I
just I'm on planes all the time I just
can't do it I just can't make it happen
so I was in LA and I said to a friend of
mine I'm like we can go out to dinner
which is you never go out on
Thanksgiving you never ever go out on
thanks you do not leave your [ __ ]
house ever on Thanksgiving I don't know
why I forgot that I don't know why that
didn't died there for whatever reason
that idea didn't register I'm like well
I'm in LA and things are different with
it but you don't you sit on your couch
and you [ __ ] eat stuffing and you
listen to your aunt talk you know talk
about queueing on what you don't do is
[ __ ] travel you just don't do it it's
just not what you should do and I forgot
that and I and I was looking at places
that have Thanksgivings and I find this
place in Calabasas which is where like
the Kardashians of it's out by Malibu
about an hour from my home in West
Hollywood it's about a solid hour it's
out there in the canyons with Kanye and
[ __ ] you know there's big houses out
there and you know go [ __ ] your mother
money and they have this place called
The Saddle Peak lodge and The Saddle
Peak Lodge Rogan loves it it looks like
it's got it's got big moose heads and
elk and you know it's a [ __ ] Lodge
you know it it looks exactly what you
think you know some Illuminati you know
Mason Lodge would look like and it's in
Calabasas and supposedly you know it's
good food or whatever so I'm like oh
we'll do it and it was hard to get in
because I ladies got a lot of people
that came to LA and for whatever reason
they're still in LA and they are just
they go out to dinner because they're
either older or then I mean we were
looking around we got to this rest first
of all it's a
our it's raining it's torrential rain we
get into an uber my friend shows up my
house we're getting a [ __ ] uber it's
torrential rain it's a it's 56 minutes
in torrential rain in an uber and by the
way it's not it's through canyons and up
Mountain it's crazy we think and there's
people that are rich so and we got a
late reservation at 6:45 so the people
on the road are already drunk they're
already coming back from things hammered
so like the guy stopping and she's
swerving in and out of lanes just to
avoid these people that are shit-faced
and left their [ __ ] family party so
we're heading to this [ __ ] we're
heading to this Lodge in the middle of
[ __ ] nowhere to have a Thanksgiving
we get there we get there and by the way
when I say this place is hidden it's an
understatement
it is dark you cannot see anything my
friend is mad my friend who I love but
he's like he's a pouty [ __ ]
like he's pouty he's one of these guys
who doesn't tell you he's angry he pouts
he's got the frame of a woman he [ __ ] a
lot of hot chance he's got the frame of
not now he's got a girlfriend but he's
got the frame of a woman and he acts
very womanly in and and you know EEE
pouch he pouts he wins he wins in pouts
you know and so he's like already wining
and pet so as soon as we get into the
[ __ ] uber it's a problem go far away
all right all right you know it's far
away um we get there there is an
ambulance outside there's a stretcher
outside I walk in I tell them I said we
have a reservation for two for 6:45 uh
the the maitre d or the Hut whatever she
goes okay
we're having a little issue here because
there's two ambulances outside in any
stretcher and I said oh that's good I'm
having an issue - it's called
Thanksgiving dinner and it's it's 6:45
for two people that would be my issue
and I'm glad that you're having an issue
but let's all have the issues together
let me have so she I'm not taking those
[ __ ] is what I'm saying if you're
killing people with your food and
they're leaving in stretchers that's
clearly not my issue now many of the
people in
la because they are demons from hell
agree with me and they are now mad that
their tables are not ready and an
uncomfortable amount of people are now
start out
cluttered around the maitre d and we
don't give a [ __ ] and we do not care at
all so the the EMTs come in they bring
down this nine year old woman who's
bombed who's just the whites in hit her
or whatever and she's asleep and they
put her on the stretcher and and they
take her out by the way this is great
Thanksgiving you just show up to the
restaurant and and somebody's leaving in
a stretcher that's it's a great welcome
Happy Thanksgiving
so we get there there's this old woman
on a stretcher hammered asleep okay and
and we're having none of it cuz we've
all been waiting 15 or 20 minutes I'm at
we're having none of it okay we're mad
at this woman we're judging her somebody
else cuz I bet she's just drunk and I'm
like I bet she is too
she's just this 90 year old woman came
here and she got shit-faced and now
she's got you know whatever she fell
asleep at the table or whatever so I go
to answer they clear the nine year old
woman out I go back to the hostess and
go listen there's clearly a table open
now right I mean there's clearly we I
mean she's out so and she goes well I
don't know if her party is going to
leave and I go you you don't know if her
party is leaving they're gonna sit that
one of them just got taken out in a
stretcher and they're gonna sit there
any cranberry sauce kick him out get him
out of here and she goes well I don't
know if they're leaving but we'll we'll
see don't worry we're gonna set the
table shortly it's it's like amazing to
me some guys in there with a service dog
a little collie who's running around
with the service and I said I said to my
friend Michael I said god help them I
said if this food is not good I am gonna
leave in a stretcher because the reality
is there's no oberst III I was like
there's no way and whoever's gonna we're
[ __ ] and I'm genuinely gonna call an
ambulance to leave if I have to I'm dead
serious no no no part of me is kidding
I'm like I will call an ambulance and
give a fake name like I've done many
times
four and I will kick the door open and
jump out of the ambulance and leave okay
and my Michael is getting a little
uncomfortable cuz he knows I'm not know
part of me is kidding so we finally sit
down in this [ __ ] Lodge and we're
looking around and I mean it is it is
the Damned it is the Damned in this
place people without families older
people there's like a mom with two older
daughters you could tell that dad just
died like they're very sad and you could
tell the dad just died there's a table
of like older people one guy literally
says loudly to the whole table of people
he goes I wasn't supposed to be here so
that's the that's the mood everyone's in
some people are leaving in stretchers so
everyone knows that they're there
because they failed it whatever you're
supposed to be in a home with family
you're not supposed to be in this lodge
now now to top it off the food is also
atrocious which is great it's
Thanksgiving catering hall food it's but
it's just bad it's just not good I'm
sure it's a decent restaurant when it's
normal so I'm like the food sucks and of
course my friend there's this new thing
where people start defending the
restaurant now like this happens a lot
people now like what I'll comment on
something people start defending the
rent like my friend Michaels like you
know it's very hard to make food for
this amount of people I'm like well then
do it for free if it's that hard we're
all paying money for this figure out a
way to do it I mean this is grotesque
one guy just literally yells at the top
of his lungs I swear to God in the
middle of the ego's it's not hot and
then he's with some chick she goes I
like it cold and he goes well I don't I
want it hot it's Thanksgiving so the
poor manager goes over to their table
and this guy I wish had a photo of them
he was just he was the same guy that
said I wasn't even supposed to be here
he's having a full-on breakdown because
this is his life it is bad and it's
Thanksgiving and we're in the middle of
a rainstorm in this [ __ ] hunting
lodge and he's at this table of people
and no one cares about anybody and
there's no love and all we want is the
food to be [ __ ] hot
make it hot and he calls the manager
over and he goes listen he goes I want
it hot it isn't hot he swear to God he
goes like this to the manager he goes
put your finger in it the managers like
I don't want to touch it
I believe you the man just like I
believe you the guy's like no touch it
the guy takes the manager's finger and
he puts it in the stuffing and mash
smash goes yeah that's that is called he
goes ok so the manager now the poor
manager is shot
everybody here is shot it is a rainstorm
it is nasty
we finally get through dinner it's not
good you know one of the waitresses it
was an older woman she was funny what
kind of we're kind of kidding around
with her and um at the end of the meal I
go to try to call an uber and there are
no cars available there are no cars so
we were in Malibu we're in a canyon
there are no cars there is no way to
leave now we now we now cannot leave and
so we finally get an uber he's like you
know I don't know 30 minutes away I mean
it's ridiculous he's like 17 minutes
away he finally arrives and I don't know
where he is now so I call it and this is
the thing that uber drivers were they
they they don't they can't hear you but
I think they can't hear you and they
just keep saying hello like I was like
where are you and he's like whole I'm
like where are you I forget his name was
like are mean I'm like are mean where
are you is like oh ho I'm like are mean
he goes I am a field place I'm like
you're not here I mean you're not
anywhere I said now I am in the middle
of the canyon in the rain I've left the
restaurant I'm walking up a block in the
rain about to get [ __ ] pummeled by a
mountain lion screaming into my phone
army where are you I'm getting wet our
meat I'm wet so our mean just hangs up
and cancels the ride which I get charged
$13 for and then I get [ __ ] got to go to
uber and be like okay the guy didn't
show up the guy's nowhere to be found
so we go back in this place we go back
in the place we're now sitting at the
bar and then this place also attracts
just
there's a there's a type of rich person
in California who's very earthy and like
their old hippies and their parents were
hippies but they have a lot of money and
they inherited these big houses and like
Laurel Canyon or Malibu or whatever and
me abandoned into some of these houses
and they're like you know and they these
people look like [ __ ] but they're loaded
and they're all sitting at the bar and
that's the guy that goes you know we
should all go to Target I'm like that's
not a half-bad idea it is Black Friday
so finally we call over the maitre d we
go can we get a cab so she calls a cab
the cab is an hour away so we have to
sit we're sitting now at the bar now you
think the people in the dining room are
damned you have no idea the group of the
crew that is at the bar on Thanksgiving
at this hunting lodge okay one guy is
literally literally just talking about
cancer to no one he's sitting at the bar
and just talking about different kinds
of cancer and every now and then the
bartender nods and fills up his glass
and he's just going on he's like yeah my
sister there's Hodgkins there's
non-hodgkin it's just so and then me and
Michael they're Michael's of course
being a pouty [ __ ] she's like you know
is a lot of money this was a lot of
money and you know he's peanut Conte and
you want to just hold off and smack him
in the face you know and we're waiting
there we're waiting there when it
finally the cab comes this is now we get
in the cab now it's a solid hour to get
to the comedy store in the rain in the
traffic and the rain or in a cab a
hundred dollars to get back to us
Hollywood the whole night to dinner was
300 there was a hundred and the bruh
back was a hundred so is a $500 night
the food was horrific it was just maybe
one of the worst experiences we've ever
had the room full of people we were we
were all aware of how we looked at each
other like yep and just gulped because
we knew why we were there we were there
because we had made choices that led us
away from the warmth of others we've
made choices that have led us in the
other direction of the embrace of our
loved ones we had gone the other way and
now we're sitting in this [ __ ]
hunting lodge eating cold lobster
bisque it's not even lobster bisque it's
literally butternut squash soup that
they just threw Lobster in it's
literally I I put the waitress over I go
this is butternut squash soup she starts
laughing yeah I'm like you can what are
you doing okay I just you shouldn't
leave your home on Thanksgiving
Christmas you can go out Christmas is
different Christmas has a different vibe
there are people that go out for
Christmas it's split up into two nights
Christmas Eve and Christmas Day so some
people will go out on Christmas Eve or
some people go out of Christmas Day and
they do the family the other night and
some people have to do Thanksgiving if
you're in a restaurant you are damned
you are absolutely 100% damned
that is it you have made poor choices
and this is that and it's sad it's very
very sad you know and it really just it
[ __ ] really made me think in that cab
on the way back and then my friend
Michael goes to sleep he just starts
Slee he sleeps the whole ride back
because you know he's the god of trouble
getting up in the morning so I just have
to sleep so I'm alone I even no one to
talk to and a service there's no service
and it's just the rain and we're just
driving through this Canyon and we're in
traffic and I look at all the other cars
and I imagine they have families and
them families whose tummies are all full
with Thanksgiving food and I'm come now
like hungry again because it's two hours
into it